if I coven if I'm going to put on my
front doorstep hey people think I would
not then be able get celibate it's just
not a thing in Australia this is gonna
take a while so we need a knife I reckon
we need to take out the guts so Scott
we're off to a good start take a while
that's pretty clever the way you're
doing it now you gotta get out yes yep
okay oh yes looks like a million little
orange spiders should be coming out of
me now we need to fist out the sades to
fist out this yeah it does feel cooler I
know just get in amongst it oh hey it's
hands on it's like it's better than TB
oh I feel like I'm squeezing some with
the insides I'm ready for the face yeah
let's do it
what shape eyes are you making square
square well you gonna make a circle do
it can you do a circle at least triangle
you know when you do your makeup and
like one eye is always better than yeah
yes I feel like that's happening to this
pumpkin okay let's do the math so it's
got teeth yeah like we could get old we
could make one of those vomiting ones
gotta say like this is really tough the
nurses must just Fred this time of year
like Oh Kerry we've got another pumpkin
injury didn't the UH other words Owen
ever man bad well done and he looks so
happy I wish I was as happy as this
pumpkin meet Nigel the pumpkin god damn
that was just too much it was fun I'm
happy with the end result we're really
proud of our child here filled with
absolute joy just absolute joy I say we
bring the tradition over here I
commissioned yeah yeah pretty good what
are you working Harry I agree I think
for Aziz who know absolutely nothing
about Halloween and I've never really
celebrated it that's pretty good
I've you know graduated University
graduated high school but this that's my
greatest achievement we created a
masterpiece tonight we did we did yeah
happy Halloween ever life